sometimes you can sort of feel like
you're riding a propaganda wave from
right-wing media one example would be
the hydroxychloroquine wave where it
built and built and built where
everybody was talking about it fox news
and donald trump and everybody's
hydroxy and then all of a sudden the
wave crashes and that's it
hydroxychloric when nobody ever talks
about it again and right now the
propaganda wave is around the regeneron
monoclonal antibody treatment for covid
as an alternative to the vaccine as
something that tells us you don't really
have to worry that much because we've
got the monoclonal antibodies available
for whoever needs them and case in point
on fox and friends uh one of the three
hosts ainsley earhart
big purveyor of propaganda
falsely claimed
that
since you can get the regeneron
treatment
after getting infected
that's basically like getting vaccinated
now that's completely untrue again the
context of the clip is uh republican
governor greg abbott who tested positive
in texas we covered that story talked
about it um let's uh let's listen to
what ainsley earhart had to say you know
what's interesting uh greg abbott we
he's in our prayers this morning because
he announced that he tested positive for
covid yesterday he has been vaccinated
and he's still got covet um but i think
he's doing okay he's by the way that's
always like a slight hit at the vaccine
vaccinated and still got it getting the
regeneron no symptoms he said what's
interesting though is if you don't get
vaccinated and you go to the hospital
most of the time you're going to get
regeneron but regeneron are the
antibodies so you're basically still
getting vaccinated because they're
sticking you with an antibody
right regeneron is the antibodies
so you're still basically getting
vaccinated because they're sticking you
with the antibodies
the virus so so guess what they're doing
er in this terribly run city they're
deciding you can't go to plays you can't
go to movies you can't go to bars you
can't go to restaurants you can't go to
gyms can't go to anything unless you
have your vaccination card right which
takes a dollar to make a knock off card
or yet there's a difference look at look
at brian kilmeade mentioning by the way
you can make a fake vaccination card for
a dollar that's a crime we'll get back
to that uh but this this is becoming all
the rage here's sean hannity on fox news
last night he's trying to talk about
monoclonal antibodies he calls them
monocolonial antibodies very aggressive
to build these
these mono colonial antibody centers
it's a big issue of colonization guys
actually it's uh it's a big big thing
okay so let's talk about it now they're
saying
vaccine what about the regeneron
treatment so first of all
the regeneron treatment is only
emergency use authorized by the fda
all of these people saying listen if i
get sick i'll get the antibodies and
that's safer than an experimental
unapproved covet vaccine the vaccine is
authorized by the fda under an emergency
use authorization
uh it's not fully authorized the
regeneron monoclonal antibody treatment
is likewise
authorized under emergency use if you
look at the fact sheet it says
is this approved by the fda to treat or
prevent covid and the answer is no this
is an
investigational drug
it is not currently fda approved to
treat or prevent any disease or
condition included including covid19 the
regeneron treatment is only authorized
under an eua and it also says it is not
a replacement for vaccination against
covid19 in the same fact sheet it says
post exposure prophylaxis with the
antibody treatment is not a substitute
for vaccination against covid19 so this
is just the new thing it's the new fad
it's the new propaganda wave that
they're writing regeneron regeneron
and by the way it just so happens that a
whole bunch of elected officials have
financial interests in regeneron so make
of that what you will we're not
necessarily saying anything about that
but that that's another thing last thing
um i want to play again for you this is
brian kilmeade mentioning you can get a
fake vaccine card for a dollar can't go
to anything unless you have your
vaccination card right which takes a
dollar to make uh if a knockoff card or
yet there's a difference so there's
brian kilmeade talking about it's cheap
to get a fake vaccine card now remember
the vaccine itself is free okay so no
matter how little you pay for a fake
vaccine card the vaccine it's safe is
free and the paper won't protect you the
actual vaccine will but i want to remind
people
it is a crime to have or to make or or
present for use
a fake
cdc vaccination card the unauthorized
use of an official government agency
seal like the cdc or the hhs
is a crime
it may be punishable under title 18 of
usc section 1017 and other applicable
laws
if you believe or you know or have
information about somebody faking a
vaccine card particularly and then using
it for something where only vaccinated
people are supposed to be or do or
whatever the case may be
you can call 1-800 hhs tips
or you can go to the internet crime
complaint center at ic3.gov you can also
call your local district attorney state
attorney general you can try local
police how much they'll know what to do
i i don't really know you might also end
up with an anti-vaxx police officer
taking your call who the hell knows but
the point here is it's against the law
and you can report it 800 hhs tips or
ic3.gov